in our artillery I will hit missile weckers
3 enemy aircraft Russian
invaders plans the island of the snake
we are all for the sake of c so alley however the proteins
continued their strictness to
establish full control over the territory of the
Luhansk and Donetsk regions
at the current time on the water movado it is even
more difficult in the area of ​​\u200b\u200bthis island and
I  honestly, we can’t evaluate and on the neck
of Alla’s birth,
I honestly optimally mats and I have a clear
picture, but for help, eat their
enemy ambushes, we keep
our development in full swing, and striking
at the island of Zhenya, the meaning of the failure of the
new technology to occupy the tilka
was there  there are strikes will be virgins
in the plans of hern publishing the plan of the chosen forces
and returning to the established control
without the last control of physical
control over the entire island at this hour of
my control, but I will help our
long-range artillery and missile troops
and artillery and aviation
here ships even before the ships  grain
zbroi wore ukraine will touch everything
i  maybe everything is possible in order to stabilize 20 in order to checkmate them all because, according to the visible structures of the wire, a wire and a boat carelessly through our territorial waters On June 30, as a step of goodwill, the armed forces of the Russian Federation completed their assigned tasks on Zmeiny Island and removed the one who was there the garrison thus demonstrated to the world community that the Russian Federation does not interfere with the efforts of it to organize a humanitarian corridor for the export of agricultural products from the territory of Ukraine, this decision will not allow Kyiv to speculate on the topic of an impending food crisis, referring to the impossibility of exporting grain due to Russia's total control of the northwestern part of the Black Sea, now the word is up to the Ukrainian side, which still does not clear the Black Sea coast near its shores, including the portside aqua toniq